c'est très bizarre docteur par exemple
quand je me regarde dans le miroir c'est
comme si je voyais une autre personne
zacharias il faut faire la
transportation aujourd'hui le coeur de
camilla est très affaibli vous savez
très bien tout ce qu'on a enduré ça fait
plus de trois ans qu'elle est sur la
liste d'attenté il n'y a pas eu un seul
donneur
mourir
tu vas vivre
tu dois me faire confiance
il s'agit d'une entreprise comme les
autres sauf que nous sauvons défi si
vous avez besoin d'un cul faire pour
sauver la vie de votre épouse nous avons
ici un large choix
valérie ya donc mariés deux enfants et
marathonienne vous avez choisi un
excellent coeur pour votre épouse
j'ai besoin d'un peu de temps parce que
je dois découvrir deux choses qui
assassine et valeria recchi à son coeur
maintenant parce qu'on l'a tué pour que
cette personne puisse vivre j'aimerais
savoir je veux savoir pour qui bat esker
savoir à qui je dois nef
si vous continuez à jouer au détective
vous risquez vraiment d'avoir des
problèmes
notre amour est tellement fort
qu'il va durer jusqu'à nos derniers
jours et même au delà après la mort